So I am going to switch gears just a little bit and talk about Waldenstrom's, which, as
you all know, is totally different.
It is a stepchild.
We heard about the stepsister.
This is a stepchild of either lymphoma or myeloma, depending on what hospital you work
at.
And we are still in this phase with Waldenstrom's where we use one therapy, like a monotherapy
of a VTK inhibitor, generally for a lot of our patients.
You can see here that we use bendamustine rituximab in some cases, but not often, as
we heard earlier with follicular lymphoma.
We are trying to move away from using chemotherapy, although if you need a rapid response, then
in those cases, we might still use bendamustine.
And we do use mid-88 CXCR4 to help us decide on therapies, and I'll show you a little bit
of data on that in a second.
And we do recommend checking TP50.
We recommend checking TP50 for 17P3 status or for 17P deletion.
Even though we're not using that yet to choose therapies, I think it's going to be a standard
in the future.
So I would say in most cases, we use anibrutinib as a monotherapy currently, bendamustine
rituximab if we need a rapid response.
So the reason we recommend checking CXCR4 status in patients with Waldenstrom's, about
a third of patients have a CXCR4 mutation.
There are more than 40 different mutations, either nonsense or frame shift.
There are less major responses, slower responses, and the progression-free survival is more
limited when patients have a CXCR4 mutation.
I included here just some data from the Aspen trial you can see at the bottom, which shows
that the depth of response is less when patients have a CXCR4 mutation.
The progression-free survival is less.
You can improve that a little bit by using zanubrutinib rather than ibrutinib in these
patients.
In relapse disease, we again recommend that you check MID-88, CXCR4, and TP53.
TP53 can be acquired in patients as their disease progresses.
MID-88 is usually pretty standard throughout, and CXCR4, sometimes the sensitivity of testing
is lower when patients are initially diagnosed, and we might pick it up later.
I think not because it's a new mutation, but because our methods of testing are just not
that great right now.
So in terms of TP53 alterations, so I do think that we're a little behind a lot of other
diseases in terms of learning about TP53 alterations, and we just have some newer data that's come
out in recent years about how that affects outcomes.
So in newly diagnosed patients, depending on the study and the manner in which TP53
status is determined, about 5% to 15% of patients will have a TP53 alteration, and there are
higher rates in relapse.
In relapse disease, particularly if patients have been exposed to chemo, and you can see
in the graphs on the top that overall survival and then time to need for treatment is shorter
in patients who have a TP53 mutation.
And these are the data, again, from the Aspen study that show us that in treatment-naive
patients, the rates are about 17%, and they increased about 27% in previously treated
patients.
And the same data here from Dr. Treon's study showing...
The same thing, higher rates in patients that are treatment-exposed, and higher rates of
TP53 alterations in people with prior alkylating and nucleoside analog therapies.
And again, the outcomes in patients with the TP53 mutation are worse.
We can overcome those a little bit with sanubrutinib, but we're still looking for better
therapies, and we're a little behind the myeloma world in terms of using bispecifics or CAR-T,
which maybe will make more of a difference for these patients than the BTK inhibitors
that we standardly use now.
So in terms of optimizing treatments or standard therapy, as you all know, the BTK inhibitors
or chemoimmunotherapy, the ongoing trials in Waldenstrom's now are trying to compare
or combine those.
So the trial that's the farthest along is the ACALA bendamustine rituximab trial, and
that shows that 64% of patients achieved VGPR, CR, and 10% undetectable MRD in the initial data
that was presented from this trial. And there's a similar trial using XANU, one in the U.S. and one
in China. We don't have final results from any of these trials yet. And then some upcoming data that
we're looking forward to in the near future is moving away completely from chemotherapy and
treatment-naive patients and using sonorotoclax with XANU. There are 20 cycles that we're looking
forward to. We don't have data from that trial yet. And then the ongoing recruitment is happening
for pertubrutinib rituximab venetoclax. It's a two-year disease treatment period, and that trial
is currently enrolling. For relapse Waldenstrom's, we have the lancas-tuximab trial, that if I
remember to show up on time, I will present that data later at this meeting, and the pertubrutinib
venetoclax trial as well. So you'll see that.
That will come up later in the meeting. And sonorotoclax also, for an indefinite period,
this shows so far an overall response rate of 76%. But we're awaiting final trial data as well for
that. Additionally, there are the BTK degraders, which I do think are going to play a big role in
Waldenstrom's treatment going forward. Overall response rate 85% to 90%, as you can see there
on the slide, in patients who were previously exposed to covalent BTK inhibitors. So I think those
are pretty high response rates and will play an important role going forward.
And then upcoming and ongoing clinical trials that I think most importantly I'll focus on really is,
you know, we don't have a lot of data with bispecifics or with the CAR-T-cell therapies
in Waldenstrom's. The first bispecific trial specifically for Waldenstrom's is the apcoritumab
trial. We have a handful of patients on that trial in our site, and actually patients are doing quite
well.
And even those with mid-88 negative disease, we have the upcoming ATTENTIMEG trial that will be
based out of Mayo Clinic. And then we are working hopefully to have some additional bispecific
T-cell trials or CAR-T-cell trials in the future for Waldenstrom's. Thank you for your attention.